Donald Trump has been the president before
with the house and the Senate.
He's appointed Supreme Court justices before.
Like, all this has happened before,
and the world didn't end, you know,
it wasn't. This didn't turn into,
you know, Afghanistan under, like,
Christian leadership. So that's the part I'm not scared at.
It truly is the empowering of his followers.
I think Donald Trump just wants money.
He's gonna do whatever he can to get as much money as he can
while he's in office. He's very self serving and.
And self whatever.
So I don't think, you know,
it's the people that follow him that are fucking nut jobs that
now, that's the world I don't like living in,
because he. Donald Trump is just one person,
but it's all his little people that are so aggressive.
Like, there's no need to be so fucking aggressive.
There's no need to be so in people's face about something that's like,
so unnecessary.
She conceded, everybody's accepted it.
We're all just saying like, gosh,
this isn't what I my was hopeful for.
But it's those people that are just so aggressive and in your face.
Them being empowered is what's disappointing
for the people who didn't vote for him.
Seeing their close loved ones that did vote for them, like,
you think that's okay,
that's